wie ich mach mal hier spanne zwischen
eckigen klammern bongo hallo ich meine
lieben freunde herzlich willkommen zu
einer weiteren folge gemeinschaft galaxy
meine stimme ist ein bisschen
angeschlagen aber genau deswegen damit
ich nicht so viel reden muss habe ich
mir den werten staffel wird dazu geholt
hallo meine lieben freunde und jetzt
beide nicht so besonders fit bist
journal die megalon unglaublich fit das
sieht man auch in der fans kämpft so
hell bei mir selber richtig schön
ich bin so fit ins nachricht an alle die
mir bei instagram folgen habe
wahrscheinlich gesehen wo ich gestern
war also war noch so ein festival wo
ganz viele farben umgeschmissen wurden
und ich wusste dass halt nicht also ich
wusste dass das festival ist es darum
nicht scheren aber ich hätte gedacht
dass man dir austauschen kann
bin dann dementsprechend damit normale
sache gegangen aber jetzt heute morgen
realisiert als das ganze mit
waschmaschinen gepackt habe das ist
nicht sauber wird und war
dementsprechend ein bisschen kacke dass
ich die ganze sache ruiniert habe ich
habe dann eine sonnenbrille verloren und
habe mit brennnesseln gekuschelt und
meine ganze sind rot und ich würde
einfach weh und es tut mir einfach leid
dass ich
so in der minor lage jetzt aufnehmen
muss für euch aber ihr wollt ja videos
ich höre jetzt auf den weg und suche
alle wüste endlich mal weil ich möchte
jetzt endlich seine verdammte ak-47 oder
so was ja irgendwie alle sind so scharf
dass die ackermänner ich habe lieber so
eine kleine helen mccabe
aber die flyers teilweise okay aber
während hersteller geöffnet damit damit
konzipieren die fragen abnehmen damit
wir uns nicht gegenseitig aus fragen
müssen in welchen farben zum beispiel du
gemeinsam beschlossen wurde oder so käme
das so vorstellen wie du da drin stehst
und dann nicht der erste irgendwie von
der seite abwirft sondern freuen kommt
an und ich drehe mich so in der schweiz
fast gelbe farbe mitten in die fresse
und hat alles im mund und ich hatte ich
heute morgen
ich hab so geduscht sondern der ohren so
gewaschen du kannst du braunes pulver 80
war meine karte sieht aus wie ein penis
die also ich hab ein nennt sich dass
dieses diese option geöffnet dass ich
mir die nase und sie einfach aus wie ein
penis und ich fliege jetzt mal einfach
für mich im penis anders meint man die
richtung ist aber wir haben ein herz
steckt genau genau jetzt ist man sich
dann damit wir uns auch darauf
einstellen können
gamestar cvi mich knoppers oder hannover
ich werde ja ich will rechtfertigt
wenn du mich noch mal sagen ich habe ja
mann gefunden ich würde sagen
wirklich ich würde glaube ich echt sagen
ich bin super mensch lotterie klassisch
aber ein kaltes ein kaltes blut
heißhunger auf knopf passen weil wir
jetzt auch so immer wenn ich irgendwie
fertig bin habe ich ein bedürfnis nach
irgend etwas komischen gestern war das
zum beispiel dass ich mir einfach mal
einen kakao gemacht habe aber wirklich
so ein zweiliter kakao und habt ihr dann
einen ganzen tag über getrunken und
heute ist einfach so bedürfnis nach
einem döner unglaublich also das ist
aber nichts komisches ganz normal ich
meine wenn man mittags aufsteht wenn wir
mit den schlafrhythmus gehabt
vorbeibringen oder alle zusammen in
einem haus in dem überhaupt über alle
drin das ist in die anderen richtige
zumkeller darin lernen lässt
wunderschönes holz gefunden sieht sehr
schön aus
dabei wollte ich mal hirschmann eckigen
klammern [ __ ] nicht warum bestimmte
personen vereinigen könnt ihr euch
überhaupt ein leben ohne youtube
vorstellen
ja also anders aber es ist ja nicht so
dass wir sagen würden auch ne ich kann
keine videos produzieren weil diese
plattformen und ich geb ich kann ich
weiterleben wie wir es machen ja so
wenig leute videos also sind schon viele
aber relations' lese ich dass ich
gesehen
sie kommen ja auch alle aus polen die
videos machen
die lehre potsdam bmw weiter also ich
weiß ich das abitur erst mal vollkommen
also gebe ich dir vollkommen recht ich
denke schon also davor haben wir auch
noch ein paar jährchen gelebt oder
irgendwie youtube-videos meistert
einigermaßen aber sonst also momentan
ist natürlich dreht sich das auch bei
mir gerade immer mehr um youtube aber
ich würde ja youtube in immer mehr sonne
nicht ja doch schon einfluss aber es
nimmt quasi immer mehr nicht auch nicht
oberhand ich suche hier schon die ganzen
morgen in welche worte um irgend etwas
auszudrücken aber es klappt hinten
liegen
ich schieße ihnen was ab will nicht
einfach es ist mittlerweile so dass
youtube einen hohen stellenwert hat in
dem leben ich mein sehr viele leute
leben davon finanzieren sich
beispielsweise das studium davon weil
man dort ich halt auch nebenbei bisschen
geld verdient das ist der tollen
nebeneffekt aber es ist halt wirklich so
dass ich würde jetzt nicht sagen wenn
ich jetzt plötzlich aufhören müsste mit
youtube dass mein leben lang keinen sinn
mehr hat und ich mich umbringen würde so
ist es nicht also bei youtube ist
wunderschönes hobby aber ich meine es
ist jetzt nicht so dass ich ohne youtube
nicht leben könnte das ist jetzt nicht
so ein medikament von roche fand darauf
angewiesen bin quasi seine droge oder so
völlig unkritisch und wirkungslose wo
ich sagen muss es ist schon so
inzwischen bei mir ist wenn ich so einen
tag lang also ich hab mal gesagt drei
vier tage bis dato gab ruhig kein video
hochladen konnte dass wir so ein
bisschen was gefehlt hat der dax über wo
ich dann gesagt hab sogar heute hätte
ich trotzdem schon gerne video gemacht
einfach gleich kommentare zu lesen oder
sonst was
und das ging aber nicht weil ich im auto
saß aber dann habe ich mich schon
gewundert weil ich dann am ende ist
super das war irgendwie immer
unbefriedigend dass er es nicht viel
erreicht so das sind ja du bist immer
unbefriedigend das ist kann sie nicht
gefühl hat wieder falsch liegen
falls nicht also ist bei mir halt das
gleiche auch ich hatte auch einfach mal
zwei monate wo ich einfach nix
hochgeladen habe weil ich sehr sehr
wenig zeit hatte ich hätte auch gerne
aus hochgeladen aber es war wirklich
diese api phase und alles mögliche auf
wohnungssuche und studium zu fund alles
möglich war da wirklich und dadurch
wirklich keine zeit und es hat mir so
ein bisschen gefehlt das muss man muss
ich echt zu sagen dieses hochladen um
sich verspürt weil einfach dieses dieses
feedback wirklich dass es um mich das
schönste daran dass man sieht was den
leuten gefällt uns weiter so erich mach
mal kurz kurz weiterhin mit mit allen
infos bei bettina york ein schreibst du
ob wir auf der gamescom sind im jahr mit
wem ich bin ich so lange die nase putzt
man jetzt einfach mal bin auf jeden fall
auf der gamescom da bin ich wieder mit
einem kumpel von mir der wenn wir auch
zusammen dieses outlaw let's play macht
mit dem man die und da wären wir dann
wieder unsere kleinen lustigen gamescom
videos machen
robin also ob alle tage
ich habe gerade in wunderschönen
dschungel mäßigen wald gefunden wenn so
die dschungel in minecraft wären dann
wäre es viel viel schöner diesen bambus
bäume seien ist das baumstamm fliegen
aber es ist sehr schön hier kannst du
dir sag ja angucken
ja auf jeden fall an gesagt du gibst du
da warst du games kommen ich weiß es
wirklich noch nicht ich war die letzten
beiden jahre da ich war beim video day
aber es war auch alles sehr sehr coole
man hat coole leute getroffen
ich weiß nicht ob ich zu dem zeitpunkt
überhaupt zu hause bin
weil die gamescom ist ja cool mein
schatten von der fledermaus
die gamescom ist wenn man über nicht
ganz genau im august irgendwann anfang
august und anfang august gehen auf und
es ist halt so dass ich quasi bald
studieren werde aber ich will davor noch
mal so ein bisschen herumreisen und ich
weiß nicht genau wann ich das mache weil
ich das umsetzen kann
deswegen ist das für mich steht das
alles auch in den sternen aber ein
spannender für die zuschauer müssen oder
nicht aber ich hatte da schon auf jeden
fall sehr viel lust drauf auf die
gamescom und fliegt mal wieder zurück
weil ich schon vorneweg geflogen bin und
nichts gefunden habe
jedes echte wüsten sind echt derbe
selten so jedoch auf den weg machen oder
schreibt stopp wir irgendwie auf eine
andere weise kakteen und beschaffen
können es wäre super wenn die anders
gehen würde weil irgendwie weiß wenn das
und das item in profitable links und
dann kommt axel stein einander in
bestimmten glücklich dass ich so schön
hier aus soll eigentlich sollte man
darüber geklatscht mit einen pieps in
meinem mit meinem ihm ein people's beim
people's geht bei dir geht nicht zu
zeitig habe zurzeit unter 16.000
anleitung mit einem 07 upload oder so
ist halt sehr sehr sehr sehr geil und
kann dementsprechend stream ich habe es
mal versucht bei giro war dann in den
kampf verwickelt mit debitor und hatten
durch konnte nichts machen weil alles so
geleckt hat und das hat mich alles mega
abgefragt und seitdem habe ich nicht
mehr gestreamt und deswegen habe ich das
ganze ein bisschen aufgeben ich würde
unglaublich gern stream
aber es geht halt zur zeit einfach nicht
allerdings werde ich bald umziehen den
und neue leitung
dann gibt es eine zwar nur 50.000 der
leitung also für youtube muss man ja
sagen
weil die meisten leute wirklich
irgendwas sechsstelliges 100.000
arbeiter oder so ich hatte etwas tut
ich habe in meinem elternhaus habe ich
auch so eine kleine entscheidung liege
aber bei mir in meiner mutter habe ich
5000 28.000 download also das geht dann
ist oft aber ist halt so wenn man dann
alleine wohnt und wieder nach hause und
dann ist so derbe langsam dann merkt man
mal wieder wie viel zeit man hat ein
video 300 minuten ab bei mir ist es auch
so dass videos derzeit braucht nur 227
minuten oder irgendwie anders geplant
sondern zwölf minuten fahrt oder oder
fünf minuten passt es halt ein bisschen
doof aber ich werde um vier kann denke
ich auch jedes wochenende irgendwie dann
am sonntag immer aber live stream machen
oder ich weiß habe ich am richtigen tag
festlegen werde weil ich hab das die
eigenschaft dass ich mich wenn ich mich
ja tage festlegen dass ich die einhalte
das ganze zu nehmen wie man tag später
kommt unter früher und deswegen denke
ich dass dann einfach mal scream werde
wenn ich da gerade bock auf ab aber halt
wirklich erst in ein paar wochen monaten
jahren ja ziehen
zwischendurch nun diesen kleidung zu
hause nehmen
ich sage ganz kurze fragen kann man auch
machen und danach beende ich jemanden
okay die sinnlichste ich habe nichts
erreicht ich bin normal fluren habe ich
die welt erkundet produktiven entstehen
ich habe versucht wurde chief zu sein
diese scheiß kapitänsbinde was geht mich
schreibt federten die kommentare bitte
wie das funktioniert dann gefühl nach
einem kurzen schock im frack könnte gut
kochen
ich bin sehr sehr koch begeistert das
musste sagen begeistert das ist die
sache recht manchmal wie im größten
liegenschaften lernt kam nicht die
abschläge hier gerade fest gegen jedoch
nicht nee ich mach das total gern das
super markieren wir das und das und das
kaufe oder ist ein alibi zusammen kochen
es schmeckt aber immer anders irgendwie
an wenn ich mir werden wir spaghetti
mache quasi dann schmecken die andere
montag anders als wenn ich mir sie am
dienstag machen würde weil ich dann in
der region zu viel wasser nehmen damals
zu viel salz und zu viel öl und alles
aber es schmeckt immer eben wie und ich
mag kochen ja die du auch also ich kann
so ich kann so ein standard repertoire
und das urteil erwartet etwa soja ich
kann reis und nudeln und quake und
kellogg's und pizza im backofen
also habe ich auch schon sagen das war's
mit der folge für heute tut mir leid das
hat alles ein bisschen durcheinander ist
und später hochgeladen wird nachher
kommt ja noch der kontakt das video mit
kühlsystem aber dass ich gott schwere
und ab morgen kommen dann paar zwei der
sturm noch ingame mit dabei ist dann
immer gleich noch ein paar auf heute
abend den wir die auf und die morgen und
danach unterbrach und dann wenn ich euch
sein und euch gefallen hat dass die
bewährte ja und wir sehen beim nächsten
mal wieder etwas gutes